- [Woman] This Great Big
Story was made possible
by P&G, Love Over Bias.
- [Man] Bayard Rustin was
one of the most important
figures in the African American struggle
for civil rights and freedom.
He organized the 1963 March on Washington.
He helped Dr. King
translate the philosophy
of nonviolence into direct action.
But a lot of people don't know his name,
largely because he was a gay man.
- My name is Walter Naegle,
and Bayard Rustin was the love of my life.
I met Bayard on a corner at
42nd Street and 7th Avenue,
Times Square in 1977.
I was 27 years old, and he was 65.
There was this tall,
handsome, very attractive man
standing next to me and
we looked at each other,
and I was pretty much toast.
Bayard was open about his being gay,
really, from his teenage years.
He just believed in
being his authentic self
and speaking his own truth.
Bayard always said that
Dr. King didn't really
have a personal problem
with him being gay.
Dr. King really needed
Bayard at different times,
because Bayard was a
person of great creativity,
great intellect, and he was doing things
for the movement that
really nobody else could do.
After the March on Washington,
he became a much more visible figure.
He was really out there in
the thick of the movement.
- We're interested in making it possible
for people to live like human beings.
About the so-called destructive child.
- [Walter] But as the movement took off,
he needed to step back and
get out of the limelight
for a while so that people
wouldn't be distracted
by the fact that hew as gay.
That was really the piece that kept him
from rising in the movement
the way he could've
had he not been.
If you were to look at Bayard and me,
on the surface, there
were great differences.
There was an age difference.
There was a race difference.
But we shared a deep bond and
a deep love for each other.
In 1982, Bayard adopted
me so that we would have
some legal protections under the law.
We were legal, father and son.
This was a time when gay
couples had no protections,
no rights.
Other people were maybe a little shocked.
It didn't really matter to us.
(serious music)
Bayard died in August of 1987.
We decided to organize a
small, private foundation
in his memory, the Bayard Rustin Fund.
It was really designed to get
Bayard into the history books.
He didn't have the
visibility of a Dr. King
or of a Malcolm X.
He would want to be
remembered for being a person
that played a great role
in making social change
in this country.
(serious music)